Shane Gillis will be making his return
to Saturday Night Live as the host of
the show after being fired from SNL in
2019 the day after being hired I went
into Lord Michael's office like I knew I
was getting fired he's like if we just
get you to the first episode people will
see you're not a piece of and I was
like if I get fired here whatever I'll
just go do Joe Rogan next week and I'll
be
fine anyway I thought that was funny
Shane Gillis one day returning to host
SNL used to be a hypothetical dream but
ever since he was arbitrarily fired from
the show Shane has been skyrocketing his
way straight to the top of the comedy
world and making SNL bend their knee on
the heels of his massive Netflix special
and Bud Light sponsorship makes this
comeback story entirely full circle most
eyes will be on Shane's opening
monologue to see how he addresses the
elephant in the room reminiscent of the
time nor McDonald hosted SNL a year
after being fired but the real kicker
will be how they use Shane in sketches
as he's been independently producing
some of the best projects on the
internet through Gillian kees for the
past few years now which has only made
it crazier to think what could have been
if Shane was